Tell me something.
You can go anywhere.
Another timeline
Another universe.
So I want to stay and fight
to save this one.
Because this is the world
where my mom lives.
I'm not going to lose her again.
Time has a pattern
that it can't help reliving.
Different people, different worlds
drawn to each other.
Like magnets.
My face is so my face.
If you were to go into the past,
you have no idea
what the consequences can be.
Bruce, I could fix things.
You could also destroy everything
just kept happening.
I completely broke the universe.
We've been waiting for you.
I created a world with no metahumans.
And now there's no one to defend us.
Want some help
If I can't undo what I did,
if I can't get back,
there might not be a future.
What's the way?
What do we do?
We try not to die.
It's not Clark.
My name is Kara.
I'm your very.
Barry, What are you doing?
Our kids are going to see this.
Welcome back, everyone. It's Charlie.
They just dropped a new flash trailer.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
references, so we'll break it all down.
Of course, I will do videos for all
the super Bowl trailers that are dropping.
There'll be a bunch of big Marvel
trailers, too, and some other surprises.
Be sure to subscribe to the channel
so you don't miss any of those.
But in the new trailer,
they just confirmed some of the twists
that we saw in the previous teaser
trailer.
Michael Shannon
Zod and Feiler are going to be
some of the big villains,
not the only villains.
There is a big twist with a dark version
of The Flash I talked about earlier.
I'll explain that in a second.
But Barry's talking to Ben Affleck's
Batman about changing the past
because he can't get over
his mother's death.
That's right. Out of the comic book
version of Flashpoint.
So he does wind up doing that.
But it seems like he accidentally travels
to Michael Keaton.
Batman's Earth in Wayne's meeting,
another version of himself
who hasn't become The Flash yet
because during the trailer
they have a version of The Flash's origin
for this other version of Barry.
But he has Blue Lightning instead, mostly
just to differentiate them on screen
so that people that don't read the Flash
comics can tell them apart.
And it seems like
the main version of the Flash
is the person that tries
to recreate that origin story.
Like, here, let's give you powers.
This is how I got powers
the first time. Let's try that again.
They also confirmed that Sasha, Callie's
Supergirl is a big part of the movie.
If you didn't hear it at the end too.
If you listen really carefully,
they play some of the theme song
from Christopher Reeve Superman
when she's flying by.
So they use some of that classic
theme music from John Williams, too.
They did the same thing with Henry
CAVILL'S.
Superman came back with a cameo scene
at the end of the Black Adam movie, too.
More Christopher Reeve
Superman stuff, obviously.
Michael Keaton's Batman, a big part of the
movie, as well as Ben Affleck's Batman.
There have been rumors about a cameo scene
from another Batman in a post-credits
scene like a new post-credits scene
after the big James Gunn reboot to sort of
set up the reboot where the flash winds up
on some other Batman's earth.
We'll see if that winds up panning out.
But generally, according to James Gunn,
the movie is intended to soft reboot
the entire DCU into his new DCU
for the new ten year plan of movies.
These are all the movies and TV
shows that are coming in.
They want to set up the idea
that some of the actors will be different,
but some of them will be the same,
and that'll all
be because of what happens in Flashpoint.
But you, starting
at the beginning of the trailer,
working our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs, WTF moments
at the beginning of the trailer
we get some new shots of the Flash
looking at his childhood home.
It seems like he's already
traveled back in time
and he's watching the younger version
of himself the night that his mother died.
Because we see the little Mary
running out crying.
We saw a version of this on the Flash
TV show in the first episode.
A lot of what happens during
the movie will seem familiar
because they use a lot of the twist
on the Flash TV show
in the first three years.
This is the shot of him on top of Wayne
Manor.
He's already gone.
But Michael Keaton, Batman's Earth.
When we get the voiceover
from Michael Keaton's
Batman, when he talks
about going to other timelines,
that's them talking about him
going to Michael Keaton, Batman's earth.
Some of these are old shots of Michael
Keaton, Batman's bat suit, his cowl, brand
new shot of Ben Affleck's Batman in Gotham
City, taking down some criminals.
It seems like
it's part of an extended action scene
that the flash winds up helping out with.
Early in the movie,
he has this new suit during this team-up
moment between The Flash and Batman.
And I believe the idea in the prequel
comic that they release for this
is that Ben Affleck's
Batman gives him the flash ring
like he designs the flash
ring in the Flash suit
that comes out of it
and gives it to the Flash.
And that's how he got this.
This explosion is just in the underground
bunker where the military has been
keeping Supergirl captive.
And it seems like it's happening on
Michael Keaton.
Batman's earth,
just because all the scenes
have Michael Keaton Batman in them.
This is her taking off in flight
after she escapes.
This is the flash traveling
through the Speed Force back in time
in accidentally winding up on Michael
Keaton, Batman's earth.
It's always interesting
to see the different ways
the movies in the TV shows
like the Flash TV show visualized the way
that he runs through the speed Force,
the way they visualize his lightning.
Part of the idea when he's traveling
through multiple timelines, the multiverse
here is that you're meant to get flashes
of other versions of the characters.
In the concept art,
they had pretty much all the big actors
from the classic DC movies
and some of the modern ones too,
like Christian Bale's Batman
with Christopher Reeve's Superman.
Pretty much everybody
from every DC movie and TV show.
So if Greg Austin gets a cameo
in this movie, best chances
are it's in a scene like that
when he's crossing across the multiverse.
Hopefully.
John Wesley Shipp
also has a cameo like that, too,
unless he's playing
some actual new character
on one of these alternate earths,
which would also make sense.
This is the main version of Flash
talking to Michael Keaton's Batman
about his powers
and why he's doing what he's doing.
Like, if you're essentially a God
and you can go anywhere in time and space
in any timeline, why are you so obsessed
with this particular one?
And it's because he can't get past
the death of his mother yet.
But that's the whole lesson of Flashpoint
like the lesson of the movie.
He has to completely fubar
a couple of different worlds
before he finds out that it's a bad idea
to use his powers that way.
We finally see the young version of Barry
with his mother and his father.
They had to recast his father
because Billy Crudup,
who played his father in the Zack Snyder
DCU movies like the Justice
League movie, had a scheduling conflict.
The Easter Egg there, too,
is that he also played Dr.
Manhattan, who's another DC character now.
Some of this looks like
a combination of the flash traveling
through time, like he's on his home street
from his childhood,
traveling through the Speed Force.
But then this other bridge shot
seems like he's just traveling
across the country in a normal adventure.
Now, if you couldn't
tell from the picture,
this is actually meant to be
Michael Keaton, Batman
looking at a picture of his parents
who also died.
And they're meant to bond over that,
like we lost both of our parents.
I'm assuming the reason why his hand is
all dirty
is just because of some adventures
they've had.
But you can see how decrepit and rundown
Wayne Manor is.
There's cobwebs,
dust all over the shelves.
So it seems like
when the Flash shows up to meet him, he's
been relatively inactive.
This just seems like a picture of him
in his childhood bedroom.
It could be happening on the other earth
or after
he started to change the timeline.
When he talks about this sheer trauma and
people being drawn together like magnets,
that's also a metaphor
for both the other version of the Flash
on this other earth,
this other Barry Allen,
but also to Michael Keaton's Batman,
because he also lost his parents.
Now, here's the thing.
When he meets the other version of himself
on Michael Keaton, Batman's Earth,
the way they're referring to this other
Barry Allen, is that they're calling him
a younger version of the character
who hasn't got his powers yet.
And he winds up being kid
flash of the movie like they refer to him
as the kid Flash for a little while
until the older future
version of him from an alternate timeline
shows up in his like the evil Dark flash.
Ben Affleck's Batman gives him the flash
ring with the new flash suit inside it,
just like the comic book version
tells him,
the worst thing he could possibly do
is travel back into the past
and try to mess with things.
They show him traveling into the past
in the events of the Man of Steel movie
are playing out again, and it's not clear
if he's on Michael
Keaton, Batman's earth, or if this is also
happening on the Justice League Earth.
Because on the Flash TV show,
for instance,
Barry does a version of Flashpoint.
He goes back, saves his mother
completely, messes
everything up in the future,
but then he tries to do it again
another time and it messes things up again
a little bit differently.
So maybe something like that will happen
in the movie where Barry messes things
up on the main Justice
League Earth and the Kryptonians come in,
it starts to destroy everything
and he goes back into the Speed Force
to try and fix everything in.
That's when he accidentally travels
to Michael Keaton.
Batman's Earth.
This is a shot of the other Barry
who hasn't got his powers yet
or is about to get his powers.
You can tell them apart
based on the clothing that they wear
and their haircut.
The other younger Barry has long hair.
The events of the Man of Steel movie
play out again on his earth
and it seems like they have to team up
to try and stop him.
But it's a little while later in the movie
because when you see them
fighting the Kryptonians,
he has his version of a homemade flash
suit made out of one of Michael Keaton,
Batman's old Batsuit.
Here's the thing, though.
I think the idea is that on
Michael Keaton,
Batman's earth, there is no Superman
to protect them from Zod.
So Zod winds up just laying
waste to the earth
because Supergirl hasn't broken out yet.
So they cause way more damage
than happened in the Man of Steel movie.
When he says, I created a world
with no metahumans, he's inside.
Supergirl is underground bunker
where she's being held captive.
But what he probably means
is that he prevented superheroes
from rising on the Justice League Earth.
Typically,
when all the producers, the filmmakers
like Zack Snyder,
the other people talk about that.
They talk about Superman arriving on Earth
and then letting the world know
about him
and them getting access
to the Kryptonian ship
That was meant to be
the beginning of that.
And it sounds like whatever he did
change those events.
So that didn't wind up happening.
All these scenes of them busting
Supergirl out of her prison
are right out of the comic book
version of Flashpoint.
We see a much bigger shot
of Michael Keaton's Bat Cave.
It looks amazing.
Obviously, they have modern
special effects now to pull it off.
This is a much more complete
version of a scene
we've seen before, like the Batwing
is in front of him and we finally see
his face in
They do the actual line, I'm Batman.
When he shows up in his suit
for the first time,
they play a little bit of the Batman
theme song by Danny Elfman.
Notice how all the equipment around him
to looks kind of old timey
because he's meant to be a 60
something version of Batman.
And all of this was created back
when he was in his twenties,
when they still had that level
of technology back in the eighties,
we had an extended action scene
where it still seems like a total badass.
The version of the bat suit that he has on
seems like just an upgraded version
of his classic suit.
Like it seems very close
to the classic suit,
but he's had 30 plus years
to upgrade it over time.
It really seems like
with some of these takedowns,
they're trying to add some of the dynamism
and comic booky nature of Ben Affleck,
Batman in the way Zack Snyder
portrayed the character like that
really cool Batman v Superman scene of him
taking all the criminals down,
but also use all the enhanced technology
that they have access to.
Now to do that for Michael Keaton, Batman.
This is just more footage
from that extended Ben Affleck
Batman scene early in the movie
where The Flash is helping him out.
This seems like a version of Supergirl
in her Supergirl suit,
taking one of the Barry
Allen's up into the atmosphere.
This scene of the Earth
cracking all around him
just seems like when the Kryptonians
are attacking this other earth
and everything just starts to break
the same way that they were doing
in the Man of Steel movie,
This extended action scene
of the both of them fighting together
seems really cool,
and I think it's meant to set up
the end of the movie
because like I said, this
other Barry Allen is meant to be Kid Flash
for a lot of the movie,
but then like an alternate future
version of him is supposed to show up
and be an evil dark version of The Flash
like a saboteur twist on the Flash movie.
Like I said,
they've already pulled a lot of the twists
that we'll see in the movie on the Flash
TV show in the first three seasons.
Like, Oh, this seems like the time
that the alternate future
Barry came back into the past
and tried to conquer
everyone and take over the world.
The main Barry Allen is in this other
Barry Allen's room
talking about
how he needs to go back to his earth
like he's already traveled
to the other earth.
There might not be a future in that earth
if I don't go back and fix things.
So it does sound like he winds up
pulling an early version of Flash point,
kind of like the Flash TV show,
and then tries to change it again
a second time here.
It actually seems like
they use the Batwing to try and create
the lightning strike, the gay Barry Powers
to give this other Barry
Allen his powers, like you see the Blue
Lightning traveling down this arc
from the bat wing and then charging
the other Barry Allen with powers.
We get a couple of extended action
scenes with them fighting the Kryptonians
one of the big differences
with this Kryptonian fight
is that they seem way more sure themselves
way better fighters
than Henry Cavill Superman was when
he fought the Kryptonians the first time.
Like he wasn't a very experienced fighter,
so he's soaked a bunch of damage
this time.
A lot of the heroes that are fighting him,
like The Flash, for instance,
has been through a lot of adventures,
so he's a lot more sure of his powers.
He knows how to use them a little bit
better.
Also, it seems that they're playing
this alternate Supergirl from this other
continuity from the Michael Keaton
Batman Earth is a slightly more stabby
version of the character,
kind of the way they did in the Flashpoint
movie, like that version of Superman,
which is a little edgier because he'd been
trapped for all those years underground.
Any time you see The Flash with Blue
Lightning on screen, that's the other
Barry Allen. Remember?
Then they end the trailer
with a funny scene of them busting
Supergirl out of her prison
and her just going ham on all the guards.
What do we do, Batman?
Just try not to die.
Just stay out of her way.
It sounds like what happens
is that he travels to the other Michael
Keaton, Batman
Earth meets the other version of himself,
and then they go try and find Batman,
then trying to fix things on his earth.
He starts asking him about Superman
arriving on Earth in his pod in
Michael Keaton. Batman is probably like,
We don't know what you're talking about.
There is no version of Superman,
but there was something from outer space
that the military is keeping.
Let's go try and find out what it was
and when they show up.
It's not Clark Kent Superman
that they find.
It's Supergirl in this tag scene of her
in Wayne Manor.
At the end
is her speaking for the first time.
We haven't heard any dialog from her
before in there.
That funny scene of them in the bat
wing with the other Barry
trying to take a picture of her flying
next to them.
Obviously, there is so much stuff
going on in this movie.
James Gunn called it
one of the finest superhero movies that
he's ever seen in the history of ever.
So I don't know what's going on,
but it makes it sound like this
movie is so amazing.
It's going to blow everyone's dicks off.
If you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
We'll get more footage for this soon.
All my other Super Bowl trailers
will post in the next couple of days too.
I believe there's going to be Guardians
of the Galaxy three,
some Ant-Man, the WASP, Quantumania,
maybe a couple of other surprises.
My Ant-Man and the WASP Quantumania
review is also going to post on Tuesday,
so look out for that.
Everyone click here for all my other
Super Bowl trailer videos.
I'll update the links
as soon as I post those and click here
for that big DC Studios trailer
that James Gunn released for the reboot,
explaining all the new movies
and all the recast actors, everything
that's going on the next ten years.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.